With so many new shows premiering, it's a
pretty competitive field, but these debuting
series have captivated audiences and critics
alike; so from streaming gems to big network
efforts, here are the very best TV shows of
2019.
When critics and audiences heard Natasha Lyonne
would be creating her own show for Netflix,
they paid attention.
Russian Doll stars Lyonne as Nadia, a woman
stuck in a bizarre time loop where she keeps
reliving her death on her birthday with absolutely
no explanation or context.
Along the way, she meets Alan, played by Charlie
Barnett, who is stuck in his own terrifying
time loop.
That leads the two of them to work together
to avoid death, solve their seemingly unsolvable
problems, and, hopefully, track down Nadia's
missing cat, Oatmeal.
"Hey man, didn't you get the news, we're about
to die."
"It doesn't matter, I die all the time."
The series' careful attention to detail, including
small recurring motifs like the ironically
cheerful Harry Nilsson song that plays every
time Nadia's timeline resets, earned the show
rave reviews, as did Lyonne's performance
in a role she seems born to play.
Along with starring, she also directed the
season finale and created the concept, an
intense involvement that has catapulted her
into praise for her work on both sides of
the camera.
Though fans are undoubtedly excited for a
second season, Season 1 ended on a rare, perfect
note.
"Thursday!
What a concept!"
Based on the famously bizarre comic book series
of the same name, Doom Patrol has been called
the best reason to sign up for the DC Universe
streaming service.
The highly anticipated series premiered in
early 2019 with a 15-episode first season
focusing on a group of misfit superheroes
trying to save the world from an eerie supernatural
villain known only as Mr. Nobody.
"Help me out here, I'm inside a donkey or
what?"
"The question is how do we get outside the
donkey?"
Doom Patrol racked up an incredible amount
of praise from critics and comic book fans
alike, and for a show that premiered on a
brand-new platform, based on a relatively
obscure DC property, that says an awful lot
about just how good and refreshingly weird
it is.
Led by Saturday Night Live standout Aidy Bryant
in her first starring role, Hulu's Shrill
is an adaptation of a book of essays by Lindy
West.
Bryant doesn't directly play West, who serves
as an executive producer on the show, instead
taking the role of a fictional character named
Annie who aspires to become a journalist while
figuring out her messy personal life and building
up her self-esteem.
"You're funny!
You're like Rosie O'Donnell."
"Ohhhh."
Throughout the first season's six episodes,
Annie stands up to her insensitive boyfriend,
attends a life-changing pool party, and makes
some pretty tough decisions.
Shrill was hailed as a game-changer for plus-sized
women in its portrayal of Annie as a complex,
lovable character who challenges stereotypes
typically seen on television, and praised
for its willingness to tackle tough issues.
With only six episodes under its belt, fans
are dying for more of the series, and they'll
get their wish.
Hulu has already renewed the series for a
second season.
An adaptation of the popular comic book series
by Gerard Way, best known as the frontman
for My Chemical Romance, and award-winning
artist Gabriel Bá, The Umbrella Academy premiered
in February of 2019 to plenty of buzz.
Fans of the original comic books and viewers
excited about a new superhero series with
a killer cast marathoned the ten-episode series
centering on a mysterious school for children
with supernatural abilities and their lives
as adults in the present day.
Born during a mysterious event when 43 women
around the world gave birth in 1989, despite
not being pregnant, these children were given
numbers, rather than names, by the Academy's
headmaster Sir Reginald Hargreeves.
After an ill-fated career as teen superheroes,
the dysfunctional family went their separate
ways, and when they're brought back together
for a funeral, they need to work together
to prevent an oncoming apocalypse.
Umbrella Academy was a hit for critics and
audiences, and the show was renewed for a
second season, with the entire cast and creative
team returning for more.
If you loved the 2014 comedy What We Do in
the Shadows, then you'll love FX's television
version, which premiered in the spring of
2019.
With a new cast and a new setting, the series
focuses on three vampires living as roommates
in New York City's Staten Island, which they
are also trying to conquer for the entire
race of vampires.
As you might expect, vampiric hijinks ensue.
"You don't seem like someone who would be
capable of killing a vampire."
"But I did it."
"Hard to believe."
"But I did."
"But maybe from a tougher looking guy, I'd
believe it."
The show was created by Jemaine Clement, who
oversees it alongside Taika Waititi.
The pair co-directed the original film, and
the show naturally shares the charming awkwardness
of the movie.
It has the same bumbling, deadpan humor that
has characterized much of both Clement and
Waititi's work, from Flight of the Conchords
to Thor: Ragnarok, and it's earned rave reviews.
Putting absurd characters in universal situations
has always been a calling card for both of
these creators, and by giving their vampires
new life, they've ended up with another hit
on their hands.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.